new york is has lost its soul i've said
many times you know i grew up there and
there was a rebellious spirit in new
york it was really rebellious and it
used to be an enclave for like if you
went downtown manhattan was like artists
and writers and people who challenged
the status quo and of course yes the
city always was liberal but they would
challenge like corporate america and big
pharma i mean big pharma would have been
a huge target by those people they would
have not been like they would have not
liked to be told what to do they
wouldn't have been like oh i got 16 you
know jabs and i'm going to be online for
the 17th one and it's okay to tell
people if they don't get a vaccine they
can't go into the deli i mean that is
not the new york that i know and i think
that was what was the big challenge for
me is that i saw a hypnotized population
just like kind of like the walking dead
i mean i hate to say it but just like
kind of robotically walking around
when i say a dystopian nightmare i mean
a dystopian nightmare
i know for a fact i got here on december
17 2021 what what day did you get here
do you know the day because for me it's
etched in my brain in stone uh i don't
remember we've been here for about four
months now but i don't you were a little
behind me you were about two months
behind me or something i was i was and
we changed our date a number of times
and then it was really funny when we got
down here the place that we had planned
to live in was not as advertised so we
lived out of hotels for a while so
that's probably why it's a little mixed
up in my head but what i do remember is
a conversation i had with my mom
when i got here and that was the one
challenge i'm a family girl so leaving
my family in new york they're not quite
ready to move yet although now my mom
just came down here and she's like i
gotta get down here
the one thing i remember feeling is just
i took a deep breath i was sitting on
the beach and i was like
wow i just feel like i shed a whole
bunch of baggage that i had on my back
in new york city there were so many
restrictions and at the time it was in
the heat of the mandates and you know
you're not my friend you're my enemy you
didn't get the vaccine and it was like
all of that just turmoil the crime and
it just felt so i felt light i don't
know how else to say it i felt like
light and airy and like i was ready to
like re-embrace life and i think i did
your show soon after that on the panel
or and you were no you you you just
sound different and i was like well did
you did that was like two weeks after
yeah yeah you were like jumping out of
your skin basically and i was like oh i
know the feeling i actually still have
that feeling yeah
yeah no 100 and i think you know for
people like uh you know you you're
coming from california i'm coming from
new york i think for people who really
believe in freedom i don't think we
realized at least let me speak for
myself there was a lot of frustration
that was in me and especially when i had
a child and i realized wow this system
is so broken and then i saw the crime
and i was like what what can i do and
there was just so much frustration
brewing that finally to be in a place
where freedom is prioritized where these
values that we hold so dear
are front and center where you know
you're going to raise your kid in a
place you know and i don't know listen i
don't know if i'm going to be in florida
forever but i will tell you this dave
i'm never going back to a blue state i'm
done
you know if i go anywhere it's going to
be maybe i go to texas maybe i you know
dip a foot in tennessee or you know have
you know florida and it's i'm not going
back to that though there's a darkness
and there's a dystopian just you know
those dystopian movies that we used to
watch and say well that's not real life
thank god yeah that's what it feels like
tangibly in a lot of these woke cities
around the country and states and i'm
just i'm not going back so for the
record i am never leaving florida they
will take me out two feet first if they
take me but i will be buried in florida
i am never leaving florida i will be
swimming with the gators
as they say dave you're committed i i
don't know what was that thing you had
on the wall at one point it was like
some florida i don't know if it was was
it lizards or the little oh what
well it was all meant to be for me
because i've actually always loved
florida my whole life and my my folks
have lived down here for part of the
year so i've always been coming down so
those what you're talking about i had
two oh you might be talking about one of
two things i have two giant alligator
uh canvases
uh these like six foot canvases that
i've had for years but i think what
you're talking about is that we have a
whole wall of alligator skin wallpaper
and one day i woke up in the morning and
there was a lizard on the alligator skin
wallpaper and i was like this is as good
as it gets listen it's commitment it's
commitment from you i love it and coming
from california you know the thing is
like a lot of people go to california i
say now
only the only sane people that would go
to california is just people who love
the weather if it's not the weather i
really don't know what you're doing
there you're not going to grow a
business there the taxes the tax
structure is just not incentivizing it's
not welcoming to entrepreneurship i
don't i don't know why you would go to
california if it's not a weather
decision but for someone like you who
does i'm guessing you're not a fan of
the cold i'm just gonna put that out
there
i don't love the cold but but
correct me if i'm wrong the the summer's
been pretty fine here i know they had
they sang it's unseasonably it's not
raining as much as usual but it's been
fine it's fine i like sweating
there you go detox
exactly so i want to ask you something
because since we come you know i'm
originally a new yorker before my crazy
eight years in cali so since we come
from such a similar place and now i
think our political outlook and our sort
of life outlook are very similar
what do you think about the people the
kind of people that were the northeast
people let's say the new york people
that should have some fight in them the
cali people a lot of them just seem
fried to me or like northern cali okay
wine country socal san diego you're just
sort of fried by the weather and okay
you just accept it new yorkers have a
fighting spirit and and that's why it
was so hard for me to see and i still
have a ton of family in new york so many
people just accept it and not only
accept it but like thank you sir may i
have another and you know they're
bringing as i'm off the grid right now i
don't know if mass mandates are back in
cali they're supposed to be right now
and they could be back in new york and
people would welcome it
yeah new york is has lost its soul i've
said many times you know i grew up there
and there was a rebellious spirit in new
york it was really rebellious and it
used to be an enclave for like if you
went downtown manhattan was like artists
and writers and people who challenged
the status quo and of course yes the
city always was liberal but they would
challenge like corporate america and big
pharma i mean big pharma would have been
a huge target by those people they would
have not been like they would have not
liked to be told what to do they
wouldn't have been like oh i got 16 you
know jabs and i'm going to be online for
the 17th one and it's okay to tell
people if they don't get a vaccine they
can't go into the deli i mean that is
not the new york that i know and i think
that was what was the big challenge for
me is that i saw a hypnotized population
just like kind of like the walking dead
i mean i hate to say it but just like
kind of robotically walking around
when i say a dystopian nightmare i mean
a dystopian nightmare and it's just lost
its spirit it's lost its soul i think
that
people have become allies of the state
you know and now it's just like a bunch
of people who believe politicians over
there they've lost that that fire that
energy and and the city doesn't read the
same that it used to it doesn't read
like a hub of cultural activity i'm
sorry but it doesn't it reads like a
crime infested
area where you're afraid to you know you
don't want to you don't want to build a
family there because you're not only
worried about the crime but you're
worried about the mandates you're
worried about what happens in cycle 2 we
all know there's going to be a cycle too
with this pandemic it's come it's coming
it's gonna be the mass maybe it'll come
just in time for the next election who
knows think you think i think but the
next time it rolls around now you know
that you know you can look around the
country and know where those populations
live where they're just going to lie
down and take it oh you want to shut
down my business okay oh you want to you
know mandate that i get a vaccine or i
can't a vaccine that doesn't stop
transmission or i can't go into a
restaurant okay like
where is their line in new york just in
terms of making decisions for themselves
and their families so i don't know what
caused it but now there's like a
subservience to authority it's like oh
you're in a position of authority you
must know better oh
i must be it's like everyone thinks
they're an idiot now oh i must just wait
i know i have common sense but i guess i
must be wrong and bill de blasio at the
time must be right it's it's disturbing
and it's a lack of autonomy and it's a
lack of self-sufficiency and a lack of
personal responsibility all those things
i hold dear they're just not there
anymore on top of that you got the crime
so you're like wow i used to love new
york because you know it was you could
go out on the town now it's like well if
i go one block over i might get knifed
so maybe i won't do that either so it's
just it's a sinking city in many
respects and you know my friend buck
sexton put a tweet out a couple of weeks
ago and he was or a few weeks ago and he
was talking about
you know you hear it sounds like a scene
from a bad movie going on outside you
know with just it's crazy it's really
really crazy um a police force that
doesn't feel supported it's just so many
factors and i i i love new york so when
i say it needs to sink i say that from a
place of love like you need to sink or
you're not you're that's going to be
your only motivation to wake up maybe
it'll wake up voters maybe it won't i
don't know i think the people who flock
to cities like that now are perfectly
comfortable
folding into a brave new world they're
comfortable with it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell